Henry were coming now to the end of this
great trip to Jerusalem where Jesus
shares so much of his gospel and his
requirements with the Apostles before
his passion and resurrection and we
noticed that as he approaches he
continues to share with them themes that
are of considerable interest he predicts
his own passion once again a theme
that's about to be fulfilled in at the
end of 18 and then at the beginning of
19 we have another of those stories
we've seen so often where the issue of
wealth and faithfulness come together
and that's the story of Zacchaeus and
how do you read those to her especially
the Zacchaeus story yeah certainly the
the passion prediction in Luke 18:31
parallels the the kind of structuring
element we get in both mark and Matthew
leading up to they the passion story and
here we have it at this crucial juncture
just before Jesus gets to Jerusalem in
effect so we get these anticipations of
the major action to come yeah there's a
key story it seems to me it kind of
brings to a culmination the important
theme of wealth and poverty that Luke
has been playing with and we've seen
Luke saying some radical things right
you have to give give to the poor and
the like here he's confronted with
someone rather like the dishonest
steward that we encountered in the
parable form he's someone who has made
good for himself by his civil service
job there and government in this case
was a little corrupt and as the kiyose
confesses it and Jesus
welcomes him and says he's going to dine
with him and as the kiyose promises
restitution and more than restitution
recompense for whatever he's done yeah
he doesn't however give up all that he
has right he's a little more like and
the soldiers and the tax collectors that
John the Baptizer might rest at the
beginning of this whole ministry and so
there's a kind of book ending that goes
on John's preaching to those folk and
Jesus preaching to Zacchaeus and I think
here the we have an example of what I
was talking about earlier on of the
council of perfection
give all you have give up all you have
before and
the pastoral application that counsel
when he confronted with a real case of
someone who has repented for his sins so
it's interesting this is one of those
cases where it's both end Lucas speaking
out of both sides
sometimes articulating this important
principle but then adapting it to a
specific situation that in any case sets
up the the story for the entry into
Jerusalem with the one last parable of a
the ten pounds again responsible use of
wealth absolutely absolutely the theme
of chapter 19 and after talking about
that he gets into Jerusalem do you think
do you think with Zacchaeus when Jesus
says you were a son of Abraham what does
he mean by that is that bringing him
back into the covenant community saying
that you made sense of Zacchaeus you're
a son of Abraham remember the Abraham
theme in the opening chapters in the
Magnificat and the Benedicta yeah and
how what we have in Jesus is the story
of the fulfillment of the promises to
Abraham and his descendants forever and
this is something that's going to be at
the heart of Luke's story going forward
that they the life of the church is a
fulfillment of the promises embedded in
the prophets
promises to Israel an Israel it's going
to be expanded to include the Gentiles
and so part of this is bringing the lost
sheep home yeah we have echoes of the
previous couple of chapters here
Matthias is a lot of people and he's
also all of these cases summed up by
being embraced by Jesus being given a
new start and by being told yes I'm
dining into a house tonight dining that
a very nice big theme and they're going
to be picking up on that momentarily
okay so here here comes Jesus into
Jerusalem on his what's usually called
the triumphal entry is this trample
what's going on what themes do you see
in here yeah just one thing one thing to
say about the overall structure here in
1928 we have Jesus going into Jerusalem
and and this begins the Lucan parallels
to the the bath ian and market accounts
and so up until now yes the chapter so
on under this overall rubric of moving
up to Jerusalem we've had this
hodgepodge of teachings brought together
in some sort of spiraling thematic way
and now we get back to the mark
inaudible remark and some of the themes
have marked the irony for instance of
this entry into Jerusalem riding on an
ass is is this an Evoque ation of
Davidic monarchy mm-hmm or is it kind of
an ironic comment on the monarch Oh Lord
a bit of claims that can be made about
Jesus it's it's ambiguous okay
in any case Jesus does enter and it's
acclaimed in him dick form blessed is
the king who comes in the name of the
Lord peace in heaven and glory and the
highest in heaven echoing Li and the
proclamation of the angels of the birth
of Jesus there are all these these these
parenthetical kinds of things at the
beginning in the end of the gospel
echoes of things that Luke has already
done and that's an addition I today the
mark inversion indicates from here on
what we get is more or less the story of
Jesus in Jerusalem as Mark tells you
with a few twists and turns a couple of
additional elements and then some rather
dramatic reformulations as in the
eschatological discourse the story of
the the last things let's come to that
and just the one the other other thing I
was gonna put on it is that that telling
the daughters of Jerusalem but this is
that Jerusalem is gonna collapse before
their very eyes which is I think in Luke
only wasn't he that's right you were
that's you and your tears and then that
leads into 21 so 2021 which is the
eschatological table for Jerusalem
there's a version of this in mark
version of this in Matthew what does
Luke do that shows us his particular
emphasis and let me phrase the question
a little differently again in in the
standard histories theologies of Luke
Luke is the one who post poems the end
talks about the time of the church yes
it's coming but there's no big hurry
about it so we need to think about how
we live in the mean time is this mean
time stuff or this get ready any minute
here he comes
yeah I think it's more the mean time
stuff if you read the version of this
set
prophecies in mark for instance mark 13
you get the sense that Jesus is talking
about something that's going to happen
in the very short run and there were
certainly a lot of early Christians who
believed that Jesus was going to come
back and there was going to be
eschatological judgment within their own
lifetime Paul certainly believed that
and by the time the book was writing
this this gospel in the 80s or 90s it's
been quite a while since those first
predictions were made and people I think
of beginning to worry about whether that
belief is correct or whether they had to
readjust their eschatological timetable
I think what you have in in Luke is
precisely that kind of adjustment and it
occurs around Luke 21:20 where you've
had a series of predictions of endtime
disasters of one sort or another and
also persecution for those who are going
to be following Jesus that's another
element of this this whole
eschatological discourse but here in
2120 you have something that's unique to
Luke when you see Jerusalem surrounded
by armies then know that it's desolation
has come near I think what Luke has done
is to have taken a prediction of the
destruction of Jerusalem as an endtime
event and looking back on the events of
70 CE II when Jerusalem was in fact
afterwards looks back on the events of
70 when the Romans put Jerusalem unto
siege and eventually destroyed it right
it looks back on that and says that is a
prophecy that Jesus made he knows of the
the tradition of these there's prophetic
tax but it wasn't something for the the
final time it was a prediction of the
war that we have experienced so that
enables you to put a kind of broader
timeframe within the general
eschatological perspective here and I
think you see that at the end of this
little story in verse 24 this part of
the prophecy in verse 24 where Luke has
Jesus say Jerusalem will be trampled on
by the Gentiles until the time of the
Gentiles the times new Gentiles are
fulfilled yeah so how long are the times
of the Gentiles
however long it takes for them to be
fulfilled that's a hint that you don't
have in the other Gospels and X is in
some ways the story the beginning of the
time times of the Gentiles exactly and
so Luke has the hope that eventually the
Son of Man will come like a thief of the
night and all that but that's something
out in the the far distant future so in
the meantime you get the church does
that in the meantime you get the church
you know it's the wax used to say Jesus
predicted the coming of the kingdom of
God and what happened was the traveler I
think think that's alright yeah I think
the wax thought that was a terrible come
down right I think Luke thinks that's
all right at the time of the church the
time of the church I think for Luke
anticipates the time of the kingdom it's
not just don't look in a very
significant way and I want to point to
one of the ways in which that happens
because one of the other things that
Luke does here in this body of material
on Jesus in Jerusalem is to tell the
story of Jesus's Last Supper yeah and he
tells it in a way that is somewhat
distinctive and that is where the other
Gospels have Jesus saying a word over
the bread at this Passover Seder and
then over the cup ik waiting the bread
with his body and the cup with his blood
Luke highlights another saying over a
cup before Jesus gets to the bread and
he has Jesus saying I've eagerly decided
this is in chapter 22 verse 15 yeah I've
eagerly desired to eat this Passover
with you before I suffer another passion
prediction for I tell you I will not eat
it again the eating motif how to eat it
again until it is fulfilled in the
kingdom of God and then he goes on and
blesses the at the first cup and he
gives another vow or prediction I will
not drink of the fruit of the vine until
the kingdom of God comes what happens at
the end of the gospel how is meal meals
meals at Jesus's resurrection yeah he
eats drinks we just decide to us
absolutely so I think that Luke is
signaling by highlighting these these
boughs we can find in the other Gospels
too but not it's not the same at all
that's right that what happens in the
resurrection and the birth of the church
is the start of the fulfillment of end
time so this in some ways a kind of
overlap between these times of the
Gentiles there's times of a film with
the prophecy that's nice because I think
I think for contemporary 21st
three Americans we think Eucharist
banquet is something to do at the end of
the church service and for Luke it's the
beginning of the kingdom that's right